this one comes from peter glenos in
canada many multiculturalists believe
that the state should actively intervene
in the preservation of cultures
and as much as they do they take on the
assumptions that the assumption that
these cultures are equal
or at least equally worth preserving
however progressives believe that
culture can improve that the culture of
today can be better tomorrow this takes
the opposite presupposition that not all
cultures are equal
because if the culture of tomorrow
wasn't going to be better than the
culture of today we can't call it
progress how can multiculturalism and
progress be compatible
let's start with the
equality of people
so from one point of view
people are
for a
decent human being at least
uh people are equal they have equal
rights
like i have the same right
to
pole vault
as an olympic champion as
we both have the same right to do it but
i'll never be an olympic champion we're
not equal in that respect it's not too
late no
i'll be lucky if i can
go a foot high you know but uh
nevertheless from one point of view
we're all equal from another point of
view were quite different
and i think
pretty much the same is true in the case
of
cultures and languages
here the questioner crucially put in at
the very least equally worth preserving
well turning that to individuals
at the very least
my right to pole vault is worth
preserving
if i find it fun to try okay
but that doesn't mean it's equal to the
olympic champion
and i think the same is true here
each language each culture has its own
intrinsic value
and the people
engaged in that culture using that
language have every right to preserve
enrich their own tradition
uh
imprint including enrich
which means making it better like maybe
they can improve the complex kinship
systems they have
but the kinship systems are worth
preserving
for them because it's a crucial part of
their lives for all of us because it
gives us insight into the nature of
human cognitive capacity
human nature human relations
so i think
though on the surface it looks like a
contradiction
i think it's resolvable
every culture every language like every
person
has
should be
equally worth preserving
meaning
granted all
appropriate rights including the
including the right to develop and
flourish and improve
like for me
i'm not going to do it but the chance to
improve my pole vaulting from
one foot to a foot and a half
should have that right
uh
but uh and the same with
my culture a lot of ways in which could
be improved i think uh we could mention
plenty of them but uh they're all
can contribute they're all
aspects of
the human general human capacity
which have the right to flourish and
develop in their own ways
you